[Music]
the subway engages in overseas
particularly in korean dramas where
every plot point seems to occur at a
subway here is two characters having a
meeting at one here is a group of men
celebrating the fact their friends just
woke up from a coma
i'm going to south korea
let's look into this subway has done a
significant amount of product placement
i'm talking of course about korean
sandwich strawberries
subway in south korea i did not come to
seoul south korea to talk about subway
sandwiches i am here for a different
story one that really focuses on this
city that is 40 kilometers from the
border with north korea but i was in the
istanbul airport on a layover on my way
to south korea and i watched that john
oliver clip and
started to go down a rabbit hole
[Music]
subway shows up a lot in korean dramas
not just like one or two but like 5 10
15 almost 20 different shows have
product placement from subway sandwiches
the american fast food chain that
is apparently the largest fast food
chain in the world by store locations
what what is going on here subway is not
cool it is not good and yet k dramas are
full of subway
[Music]
we gotta get to the bottom of this is
there something special about korean
subway like is it different or am i
missing something is something better
about korean subway versus american
subway because if there is i want to
know about it so first let's settle that
[Music]
i'll do mozzarella hot chili salt and
pepper
[Music]
be fresh okay um after that very
scientific study which by the way was a
little bit scientific because i did
choose the specialty items that only
exist in korea and not in america and i
chose something that had beef in it
which is a thing that korea does really
well so i tried to give south korea the
best chance of being differentiated and
the result is that it is kind of better
kind of eat fresh
eat fresh
eat fresh
that's my man but not really it's like
still just microwaves and like
mass-produced industrial ingredients
prepared in front of you they kind of
taste old and stale but kind of
delicious at the same time
i don't know but the thing i noticed at
this location and several others that
i've visited in my short time here in
seoul is that these subways look and
feel different cleaner more sleek well
lit so yeah i guess you could say that
subway sandwiches taste better when
you're eating them here instead of here
okay this is not what this video is
about it's not about whether or not
korean subway is better than american
subway you can decide that i'm
interested in how subway sandwiches has
taken over korean dramas there is an
explanation for this i talked to an
expert in this topic who's like the guy
to explain it he's a communications and
media professor at one of the best
universities in korea and he has
thoughts on this but first i have to do
the thing that allows me to make these
videos which is tell you about the
sponsor of today's video so let's go
back to washington dc for a few moments
and thank today's sponsor
here we're back in washington dc doing
an ad read but unlike subway in kdramas
i'm actually putting a break between the
video and this ad read that's the
difference all media has to make money
somehow i just am doing it by putting a
wall between the story and the ad so
thank you nordvpn for sponsoring today's
video a vpn is a tool that i use pretty
often especially lately as i've been
traveling being in korea my computer's
been freaking out as i try to log into
things and so to solve that i log onto
nordvpn and i connect to the internet
via the united states and this isn't
some like coding like nerd thing this is
like press one button and you're now
connected via the united states and now
i can log on to gmail and gmail is just
fine with it and no one freaks out and
we're good a vpn also allows you to
watch stuff that like isn't maybe
available in your country but you just
like connect via the uk and suddenly
you're watching like netflix uk it's
pretty cool nordvpn is also expanding to
become a threat protection tool it's a
tool that allows you to block malicious
trackers
malware and when you're like sitting on
public wi-fi in a cafe and you're not
super secure it totally gives you a
buffer of security that to me just gives
me a little peace of mind and right now
they're having a 30 day money back
guarantee if you sign up so really you
have nothing to lose you can try this
out and see if it works there's a link
in my description it's nordvpn.com
johnny harris when you click that link
it helps support this channel so go do
us both a favor click the link and you
also will get in on an exclusive deal
four months of free nordvpn to try it
out for four months thank you nordvpn
for supporting this channel back to
korea to figure out what's going on with
kdrama and subway
you know
maybe i should have done that ad as a
product placement
no i wouldn't do that you'd probably be
very angry if i did if i slipped it into
this video stop waking us name for that
and
frankly rick i i'm surprised you did
instead there was an ad break there was
a little commercial and now we're back
to the show that is a very normal model
for a lot of media around the world but
not in korea turns out that south korea
has a very different culture surrounding
advertising and media and by very
different i mean they haven't ever
allowed there to be commercial breaks no
commercials you're watching a tv show on
the television which most of you don't
do anymore but like forever that's the
way it's been and then there's a
commercial break like that is a very
normal thing we're all very used to it
in south korea that has not been allowed
it's been against the law it's been
completely regulated
[Laughter]
in korea they're obsessed with this idea
of viewership rights it's a very
aggressive set of regulations that don't
let advertisers put commercials in shows
spoiler alert that's slightly changing
but for years that has always been the
case
okay but then a few things start to
happen these broadcasters these tv
channels really started to struggle
because people were moving away from tv
and this really threatened the shows
that were being made because now they
wouldn't have budget korean dramas were
starting to see popularity and get
viewers all over the world the korean
government saw an opportunity to change
their advertising rules to let
advertisers put korean goods and
products
into the shows to advertise but like as
a part of the story not like in a
commercial that's like in the middle of
the show but like to bake in a product
to the story which is called product
placement and so in 2010 they started to
ease these restrictions and people go
nuts and it got really cringy really
fast
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yeah it was it was pretty bad every
product placement is a gamble if you
make it too obvious two on the nose
then it can actually create a negative
association with your brand and there's
backlash but what it did is it put more
money into these shows bigger budgets
and these shows got better and better
and the audiences around the world grew
and the product placement got more and
more sophisticated it's just an
interesting system in korea where rather
than drama companies approaching
advertisers it's advertisers who
approach drama companies i mean there's
a lot of money in this
one
do a couple of those and you're making
some like pretty good cash to make your
show better at first it was korean and
chinese brands which got a lot of
scrutiny people kind of hated it
[Music]
western brand american branding
and then a few years ago subway the
sandwich maker decided that they wanted
in on this
[Music]
one thing i love about this city so far
is that there are just little nooks and
crannies i'm in the middle of the city
and there's this little peaceful like
garden space look at this this beauty is
just something this is like spring in
front of starbucks subway's strategy was
very bold they decided they wanted to
own this space they poured tons and tons
of money into product placement into k
dramas as well as increasing celebrity
endorsements which is another thing that
has a lot of marketing power in south
korea they started to go nuts they're
like it's time for a brand refresh yeah
we know we're getting a lot of flack for
our tuna and our bread and all of this
in other countries but here in south
korea it's a clean slate we're gonna
establish a new brand perception through
k dramas and celebrities and that is
exactly what they did
thing about subway that makes sense here
is that like subway is a product but
it's also a place and every show needs a
set it needs a place for things to
happen it could be a nameless cafe or a
random restaurant or it could be a
subway sandwiches and especially because
the regulation made it so that you
couldn't like have the actors overtly be
like you should buy subway you can like
show the space you can show the brand
you can show them like eating it but you
can't have them like overtly tell people
to buy things which is just fine for
subway because now they can integrate
their store and their food into these
stories
excessive number of visits to locations
like subway can be quite jarring at a
certain point they can ruin the mood or
they can become comical because
nobody actually
wants to eat it subway that often
sometimes it's just a matter of like
people sitting around having a
conversation while they have like
beautifully packaged subway sandwiches
having the logo faced towards the camera
but with time it started to become more
and more intertwined with the actual
like storyline like this show about a
ghost who can't eat anything because
he's a ghost but then this man hands him
a subway sandwich and suddenly he can
eat and he's really happy and excited
because he was so hungry i'm not sure
how that makes sense in the context of
the story or like the rules of this like
ghost world but it made sense for
subway's bottom line in the budget of
this production and the emmy goes to
subway
some of these are so on the nose where
like the plot point itself is about how
delicious the sandwich looks like look
at her just like staring at that
sandwich and she's just like i want that
and suddenly i'm looking at this and i'm
like i want it too like maybe i need to
go back to subway and get another
sandwich here's a man who's dying
they're trying to revive him with a
defibrillator and he goes into a dream
state he's on the fringe of death and
like his last memory is like remembering
this date he went on to a subway
sandwiches he feeds her the sandwich and
the soft drink all with the logo
perfectly placed to face the camera i
mean it's so good oh and guess what it's
absolutely working one subway executive
here in korea told the new york times
that it is night and day the difference
between the before and the after of
product placement oh and it's not just
for swooning koreans into loving subway
remember how kdramas are becoming really
popular in the united states showing
these slick subway shops and delicious
looking sandwiches to an american
audience via korean dramas which are
exploding in the states is this bizarre
round trip of brand awareness and to be
honest it's kind of brilliant like it's
i don't know like i've only been
thinking about this for like 36 hours
but like it's kind of working on me too
like i'm having some renewed interest in
like wait is subway cool subway i love
you it's a very different thing than the
association i have and that's what
branding is it's this mental tug of war
but
this is just like branding 101 and
subway is doing a damn good job at it
through korean dramas
oh and it's not just subway that's
classier
dunkin donuts is also super nice
in south korea i've never seen a dunkin
donuts that looks anything other than a
dingy gross place but the dunkin donuts
here looks really nice i'm gonna go get
a donut
[Music]
[Music]
it's been really fascinating for me to
see all of these american brands here in
south korea who have been able to like
start afresh in this new market to
basically build the brand that they wish
they would have back in the united
states
so yeah it's working for subway but
they've also pushed it a little bit too
far there are moments in some of these k
dramas where a guy just like gives
someone else a subway sandwich has
nothing to do with the story it's like
okay product placement for brand new
products especially high-tech products
that koreans aren't using yet by
characters who in the drama might not
actually have the finances to invest in
that kind of gadget those are
particularly annoying to me personally
when you have these lines about how much
a character loves the coffee or wants
the coffee
this is instant coffee people it's not
that amazing overall
subway has come out on top they've been
able to walk the line kind of balancing
between
overt product placement that gives them
a lot of screen time while also trying
to make it somewhat natural like not too
forced and cringy and like off the plot
and they're getting better and better at
this
at like integrating it into the story so
that it's not so like awkward and
perhaps most brilliantly they've done a
good job at like kind of making fun of
themselves for like this sort of trope
of over product placement in this little
web series they did on youtube which is
like a little drama but it was produced
by subway
all about subway like the entire plot
takes place in a subway about a subway
employee and there's like a love story
with this girl it has to do with like
the plant-based sandwich and like the
steak and cheese sandwich john oliver
kind of made this sound like this was
like a really serious thing but this was
totally tongue-in-cheek satire subway
knows that this trope is like kind of
ridiculous and they're poking fun at
themselves showing some self-awareness
that definitely like disarms any critics
but then also people have told me that
this show is actually like kind of good
like they could see themselves watching
all of the episodes it has millions of
views like this is funny satire mixed
with like real storytelling and subways
at the center of it like come on who is
doing this who's in charge of this
they're doing a great job
congratulations marketing people who are
in charge of this
it's working
so product placement in k dramas is only
going to get more sophisticated more a
part of the story and more ubiquitous
placements
such a strange interesting cycle but
it's happening there's no going back
i did not come to south korea to talk
about subway sandwiches alas i am here
for a different story that i have been
reporting on while here up at the border
with north korea learning a lot about
the realities of the situation here in
the korean peninsula spoiler alert it's
quite a bit different than what we hear
on the news in the west so stay tuned
for that watch yourself some kdramas
get yourself some subway and you will
officially be on the front lines of this
weird disruptive strange time of
globalized media and advertising
and food what is happening life is weird
k bye
one of my favorite things about the city
so far is the little strips of light
that are red when you can't walk and
green when you can
so cool